this morning candidates and surrogates are
sharpening their campaign message with just
10 days to go until the midterms last night
President Biden vice president Harris and
former president Obama were out in force as many
polls including our CBS News Battleground tracker
estimate Republicans are poised to take the
majority in the house with a toss-up in the
Senate Congressional correspondent Nicole Killian
is in Atlanta where the former president held a
rally and Nicole there are more events today yeah
that's right Jeff former president of Barack Obama
will travel to Michigan and Wisconsin today the
Nevada and Pennsylvania next week he really spent
a lot of time last night addressing some of the
headwinds the party is facing from inflation to
Crime he told voters democracy is on the ballot
and urged them not to be complacent foreign
Friday hello Pennsylvania
Obama Biden both back on the trail at the same
time with the same message vote vote vote I
am here to ask you to vote in Atlanta former
president Barack Obama highlighted Democrats
closing argument to rev up the base in his first
midterm campaign appearance tuning out is not an
option despair is not an option the only the
only way to make this economy fair is if we
all of us fight for it former president
rallied in support of gubernatorial candidate
Stacey Abrams an incumbent Senator Rafael
Warnock taking several cracks at his GOP
opponent Herschel Walker seems to me he's
a celebrity who wants to be a politician
the Georgia Senate contest is one of several
potential toss-up contests that could determine
control of Congress along with Pennsylvania not
hyperbole suggest all eyes are on Pennsylvania
but some polls showing Republicans regaining
momentum Democratic Jitters Spilled Out into
the open this week when Majority Leader Chuck
Schumer was caught on a hot mic with the president
and we're gonna win period each
state voters eager to see the
former presidents that they were anxious
as election day nears I think that he can
only engender more support and we keep
on hearing about theirs low engagement
with the Democrats so I think with him
coming out he'll just energize the base
Republicans plan to bring out their own star
power with former vice president Mike Pence
set to campaign here in Georgia with Governor
Kemp next week former president Trump will
also launch a swing state Blitz right before
the election Dana all right Nicole thank you